que nous nous tirons pas de l'impasse
dans laquelle nous a plongé la pandémie
sans une collaboration une coopération
au niveau international ça n'est que à
partir du moment où nous avons collaboré
avec tous les états de la planète
nous avons réussi à éradiquer la variole
dans les années 70 80
il en va de même de ce virus tant qu'il
restera un état dans lequel le virus
pour à pulluler est muté il reviendra et
nous serons condamnés de nouveau affirmé
confinement à porter le masque à trouver
des nouveaux vaccins ils ceux ci à des
beats où vous imaginé le cauchemar que
ça représente pour les années qui
viennent
donc il faut une collaboration de tous
les états de manière que tous les états
y compris le brésil y compris l'inde
réussissent à mettre en place une
véritable campagne de vaccination l'irak
et à éradiquer ce virus ceci dans un
contexte où quand même le mutisme du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
qui n'a fait aucune déclaration sur la
pandémie pendant plusieurs mois alors
que nous étions en face d'une crise
mondiale a pour la première fois depuis
ceci a travaillé le fait à mon avis que
ce qu'on appelle la communauté
internationale aujourd'hui il est devenu
une coquille vide
on s'en fout c'est un droit onusien qui
les plus respectés et qui n'a plus de
légitimité
pourquoi parce qu'en réalité on a des
coups on savait mais c'est devenu une
manifeste aujourd'hui qu'il dissimulait
mal en réalité la toute puissance
américaine la toute puissance des etats
unis aujourd'hui n'étant plus notamment
à la faveur de quatre années du tchad
et puis la montée en puissance de la
chine il faut repenser je crois
aujourd'hui le droit international de
manière à pouvoir prendre en compte des
drames aussi colossaux que sept points
du mans
[Musique]